alright let's get started today we are
going to complete our discussion of
consumer choice by actually coming back
and deriving the demand curve that we
started the semester with actually
showing you how from the limited set of
tools we've given you we can actually
derive the underlying demand curves that
we've seen in this class I'm gonna spend
the rest of lecture than talking about
the elasticity of demand what determines
the shape of that demand curve I'll talk
about how changes in income affect
demand and then we'll come and we'll
come back talk about the effects or
price change and we'll talk about sort
of the theoretical concepts underneath
how you analyze a change in price in the
economics model so let's start with
deriving demand curves deriving demand
curves okay so we started in this class
with the demand and supply curve and I
said would say where they came from
so basically we're now gonna talk about
how do you derive from the tools we've
learned so far the relationship between
price and quantity demanded the downward
sloping relationship between price and
quantity demanded that we showed you in
the very first lecture so let's to do so
let's return to our example from last
time
remember exam from last time as utility
function was of the form u equals P
times C okay your parents had given you
an income of 72 dollars with which you
could buy pizza and cookies pizza at a
price of $12 and cookies at a price of
$6 okay that was a parameters our
example from last time and once again
remember all I've done is given you
stuff here obviously your dis this part
is non-controversial as a price for
pizza and the market price cookies in
the market there's an income this amount
of money your parents give you that's
all uncontroversial and this is just a
sensible assumption of what someone's
preferences might look like all I'm
saying is with these four things we are
done with these four things we can now
derive a demand curve and how's that
let's start by looking at it graphically
in Figure 4-1 okay
figure for one on the left-hand side is
exactly the kind of a difference curve
analysis that we did last time so we
start with budget constraint BC 1 okay
that is something where you could either
get up to 12 cookies and no pizza or up
to six pizzas and no cookies okay and we
know from analysis last time given this
we showed you last time and you went
home and practiced and we're so excited
you told your mom and everything we told
you how you could show that you'd want
that you'd want six cookies and three
slices of pizza at a point like point A
okay we showed that last time now we
also talked about happen when the price
changes so for example imagine that the
price of cookies rises to nine dollars
okay well we know the price cookies rise
to nine dollars it's that you could
still on your budget afford six pizzas
so the y-intercept does not change but
the x-intercept changes now you can only
afford eight cookies so you move to BC
to sub to you used to be able to used to
be able to afford 12 cookies not going
to afford eight cookies and most
importantly the slope of the budget
straight has steepened remember what is
the slope with the buckets budget
constraint it's the slope of the budget
constraint the slope is minus p OC over
P P that's the slope and that's deepened
because the price of cookie says there
is it so you don't have a steeper budget
rate to slope used to be minus 1/2
now it's minus 3/4 so now that's gone 4
minus 1/2 2 minus 3/4 with this new
higher price for pizza a high price of
cookies I'm sorry in the price cookie
shows to $9 that budget constraint has
steepened okay what is this due to
demand for cookies well we find the
highest tangency of your indifference
curves with this new budget constraint
and you could solve mathematically to
show that that will occur at point B
where you will choose to continue to
have 3 slices of pizza but to only have
4 cookies that is what happens if you
take this
you could streamed optimization if you
change this price to nine reoptimize the
way we showed you last time you didn't
up finding that you would want you would
want a 4/3 slice of pizza and four
cookies at point B okay now what if
instead the price of cookies fell to $4
so cookies got more got cheaper well in
that case now you could still only
afford six slices of pizza so the
y-intercept once again doesn't change
but the x-intercept now moves out to 18
because ninety can't afford 18 cookies
so your new budget constraint is flatter
its BC sub 3
it's the flatter outermost budget
constraint your opportunity set is much
larger because cookies are cheaper you
can see amount of money from your
parents but it can buy more stuff and
we're gonna buy more cookies so your
opportunity set is larger so you now can
reoptimize with a now flatter budget
constraint the slope instead of being a
half has now fallen to a third okay the
price goes over the but the price
cookies is four dollars the price
cookies over the price of pizza is now a
third so an absolute value the slope is
lower so you can now and we say that if
you take the same utility function and
optimize that the new price at a price
of cookies of $4 you will find that you
will choose point C still three slices
of pizza but now nine cookies so all
three of those points we simply did by
doing the redoing the optimization I did
last time
by taking this utility function
maximizing it subject to a budget
constraint dictated by these parameters
and all you was change this parameter
twice once I may change it up once I
change it down okay questions about that
well you've now derived the demand curve
oh yeah I'm sorry question
know your fundamental your indifference
curves undeterred by utility function
your different scores do not change it
changes which indifference curves you
end up choosing because the tangency
point changes but the only change you
ever Square will be changed utility
function dearest cars purely come from
this part of it
so difference curves come from here
budget constraint comes from these
pretty three pieces okay
yeah well no but it is possible to take
a bunch of demand curves to collaborate
them to get one demand curve I'm gonna
talk about that later but no
indifference curves you can't really add
up because remember you Dalls are not a
thing so you can't add up indifference
curves but when I have people which you
have demand curves and we've now derived
the demand curve have we done that well
what's the demand curve it's the
relationship between price and quantity
well I just showed you Liz you mean
price in quantity when the price goes
down quantity of cookies goes down goes
up when the price goes up quantity of
cookies goes down well he just shift
over to the right hand side a figure for
one there's a demand curve
I just graphed these three points I just
graphed for each of the different price
of cookies I gave you how many cookies
are demanded okay well at a price of
cookies of six our initial price Jesus
is really small six cookies whereas
we're demanded okay when the price of
cookies goes up to eight I'm sorry when
it goes up to nine only four cookies are
demanded when the price of cookies Falls
to four point C then nine cookies are
demanded so literally we've just arrived
the demand curve starting with these
primitives your tastes your preferences
and your budget constraint we've derived
a demand curve that's it that's what
demand curve comes from okay and that is
um that's essentially what is underneath
the demand curve what's under the demand
curve is the fact that as the reason to
may incur slope down okay is that as the
price goes up you want less of the good
because with a given utility function
that price goes up you want less of the
good and that's why demand curve slopes
down okay
so we've just arrived that
okay questions about that yeah great
question did you peek at my notes
no because you if you had you would have
said that's exactly the question I would
have asked you so since you asked me
I'll answer it no it is not always true
in fact that is a feature of this
particular utility function I've chosen
this particular utility function I've
chosen gives the feature that the demand
for a good is a function only of your
income in that goods price not of the
other goods price that's a feature of
this that's why we like this utility
function okay it has that nice feature
in general that's not true in general
when the price of one good changes it
will affect the demand for all goods not
just that good itself so the more
general utility function that would not
be true with this utility function it
gives what's called the flat price
consumption curve okay not a term you
need to know but just if you wanna be
more technical which is basically least
utility function demand for any good is
a function only of its own price in your
income therefore when other prices
change it doesn't affect the demand for
that good but that is not generally true
in general when you change the price of
one good demand for all goods changes
okay questions about that okay yeah oh
what no matter what number I chosen but
the bottom line is the number as a price
cookies changes the number of pizza
slices would never change
demanda would never change that's the
feature of this of this particular
chilli function it's a nice feature of
it okay
once again that comes to this trade-off
with modeling I've chosen a simplified
utility function with this nice feature
it's almost certainly not true okay but
we once again allow it allowed us to the
ride very sensible demand curve without
introducing other complications okay now
what determines the XI this demand
curves particular shape what determines
the shape of this demand curve and that
leads us to the second topic I want to
cover today which is the elasticity of
demand
the elasticity of demand what determines
the shape of a demand curve is what we
call the elephant elasticity of demand
which we define as we define the
elasticity of demand epsilon as Delta Q
over Q over Delta P over P it's the
percentage change in quantity for a
percentage change in price so for
example if quantity falls by two percent
for every 1% increase in price that's
the last is demand of negative two so
that's the C of demand as long as demand
cars are downward sloping is less than
zero because the price goes up quantity
Falls okay
slots tissa t demand is less than zero
okay and less I'm sorry less than equal
to 0 less than equal to zero yeah great
question when we're doing this if we did
it in calculus it would be
infinitesimally exelon change so it
wouldn't matter for this new or old
quality when you do it discreetly use
the old quantity okay so I should say Q
0 and p 0 once again if you did this in
calculus which is the way we're sort of
thinking about an underlying intuition
it's an epsilon change so Q 0 and p 0 or
epsilon it doesn't really matter but if
you do we just create lead want to use Q
0 and p 0 okay there's a great question
it's keep them coming
okay now whenever we think of constant
elasticity it's always useful think
about the extremes so what me extremes
this measure one extreme would be if the
elasticity mand was zero we would call
that perfectly inelastic demand would be
epsilon equals zero now extremes never
exist in the real world okay but we get
but there are cases that come very close
so can someone without flipping the page
of the handout don't do it because only
for flip relations and give me an
example of a good that might have
perfectly in a very very very inelastic
demand we're no matter the price you'd
still want the same quantity
yeah you you water something that's
essential life like water what else yeah
in the way back well insulin is the
classic example we use okay yeah
sewage removals interesting although not
quite because we see a lot of variation
around the world and sewage removal but
something like that baseless centrioles
of life insulin is a classic example we
use indeed that's example I do use in
the next so I guess I didn't list it on
here so you could have turned the page
we think about perfectly the last demand
someone once again for those of you who
don't know about the medical science
here basically if you're diabetic you
have trouble controlling your blood
sugar insulin is a medicine you take to
help you control your blood sugar
without it you die so you'd think that's
pretty either last time in like I want
to live so I'm gonna want to have my
insulin and if the price goes up I'm not
gonna say now just die okay you're gonna
want to still have the insulin so we
think in that case quantity be fixed at
some Q which is the insulin you need to
live and it wouldn't really matter what
the prices so the elasticity would be
zero you have a perfectly inelastic
curve quantity would not change with
price okay basically that would happen
when there is no plausible substitute
okay
the reason water is not as good as
insulin is because I can drink something
else and sewage removal I can do other
things to deal with the sewage in my
house but is then there is no substitute
I die okay so basically the bottom line
is V when there's no plausible
substitute they may be perfectly
inelastic likewise we consider yeah okay
this is a market that's a great point
I'm just doing this as let's actually
imagine there's one company for now
you're right I'm not doing choice across
companies okay so that would be so that
would be perfectly inelastic we can all
sue to the other extreme perfectly
elastic so what's an example perfectly
elastic demand perfectly elastic demand
is that part of last demand is that
epsilon equals negative infinity
okay so what what what would cost
perfectly inelastic demand people raise
their hand and and tell me perfectly
perfectly elastic a perfectly elastic
demand I'm sorry
well cause perfectly elastic demand what
would cause it I'm sure to try spread it
around a little bit yeah that's
interesting I mean it wouldn't that's
not I'm gonna come to that but that
wouldn't that's something where demand
will be less elastic but not perfectly
not close purl elastic because basically
well then I ask a question this way what
would drive a good - very very elastic
demand in general yeah exactly perfect
substitutes diamonds like doughnut
perfect substitutes I mean they're
increasingly making fake diamonds that
are better and better substitutes but a
real diamond still doesn't have a
perfect substitute so what does what's
an example this up with a very good
substitute yeah a spork
there is no sub I am insulted that you
would suggest at the great spork you
need two different things to replace a
spork and a fork
no I reject your spork suggestion I'm
just joking know what what else what
else what is something that's really
good substance yeah yeah something which
is an off-brand medication or like I
like think of like a fast food okay like
like make like fast-food burgers and
pretty good substance fast food pizza
okay basically it's once again it's hard
to think of an extreme example nothing's
ever perfect elastic but things which
have very good substitutes okay tipping
this works well we think across brands
okay think about different brands of gum
geez I mean who the hell cares or
different brands of fast food yeah
that's a separate issue let's come back
that's sort of a separate that's like a
key a weird kinked budget constraint
that's not really about substitution but
the bottom line is we don't need more
examples the bottom line is we the key
element to and we show that in Figure
4-3 that's gonna be a horizontal demand
curve with a perfectly elastic menu
horizontal demand curve and therefore
price never changes because with a
perfectly elastic demand this it's sort
of a weird way to think of our last
demand the way it works if if I ever
charge with her last night if I ever
charge the price 1 epsilon above someone
else I'd lose all my business and if I
charge a price 1 epsilon below everyone
else I would have the entire market
because if it's perfectly elastic like
if one pack of gum I don't know what
these stupid gum thing orbits and
ellipse or whatever if they charge like
a penny more than someone else know
would buy them they go out of business
ok that's the idea here and that's why
the price you can't change the price is
fixed if anyone deviates from that price
boom they need to lose the market at the
whole market yeah
there's not really a market for dollar
bills there's not really I mean you
could say the demand for cash in general
might be fairly elastic because you have
credit cards and things like that that's
interesting idea yeah
so basically when your perfectly elastic
demand you end up with sort of this
constant price and quantity and and
quantity changes but price doesn't
change okay so that's kind of the
extremes now um in so in general we have
goods that are more and less elastic
okay in general we end up within this
range and probably elastic imperfectly
the last thing the bottom line is here's
the intuition I want you to have what
determines elasticity is
substitutability the more substitutable
goods are the more elastically demanded
they are okay
so now now I want to go on to another
topic which is related which is we
talked in our example about what
happened when I change prices what about
when I change income so the third topic
I want to talk about is what happens
when income shifts and how does that
affect demand curse when income shifts
how does that affect demand curves okay
well we can do the same exercise we did
before we did an exercise before we said
well let's just use the tools we used
before to solve for your new choices at
different prices let's just solve for
your choice if you're an income so let's
go to figure four four okay figure four
four once again we start with BC one
same parameters as before same setup as
before okay we choose point a now let's
say I raise your income from $72 to $96
you've done well your parents are giving
you more money $96 well in that case you
will choose to have both more pizza and
more cookies given this utility function
you will choose the point you will
choose point B okay you will choose
point B okay likewise if I lower your
income from $70 to $48
then you will choose point C okay so as
your income goes up you'll choose more
of both as your even goes down you
choose less of both okay so now once
again you'll notice this well let me
come to that so basically what that says
is I can trace out the relationship
between how your income changes how your
demand for cookies change I can go and
grasp that on the next graph and
generate what's called the angle curve
the angle curve is the relationship
between income and quantity demanded and
we'll come back to why this matters okay
the end curves relation to income and
quantity med now here the Elven curve is
linear once again that's just a feature
of this utility function in general
doesn't have to be linear but here the
out curve is linear that's just because
of the way we struck this utility
function okay and the slope of the angle
curve is what we call the income
elasticity of demand okay
gamma which is Delta Q over Q to 0 once
again if we're doing discretely over
Delta Y over Y 0 that's the income
elasticity of demand okay now now let me
just say let me just say one one comment
here about this because there's sort of
a big sheet that I'm doing here with all
this that I need you guys to be aware of
which is which is constant elasticity
versus linear curves we know a constant
elasticity curve will not be linear okay
if it's linear it's not constant
elasticity because he unless if it's
salinity the elasticity will change
along the curve okay so the demand curve
I just wrote I drew in Figure four one
that was a constant elasticity demand
curve that's why it was curved this
angle curve I drew here would not be
constant elasticity because it's linear
you could you can calculate for yourself
that the percentage change the income
elasticity will shift as you go along
this curve and you could show that you
can show yourself that what we're gonna
do in this class is we're gonna draw a
linear constant elasticity curves which
is of course technically wrong
just think of them as blown-up versions
of a large demand curve everything is
locally linear right once again for an
epsilon change everything is linear so
the truth is we're cheat a little bit
and often draw a linear constant
elasticity curves and I want to own that
that's a cheat okay but just if
everything is really local it's not that
bad a cheat okay so so that's kind of
how we're good that's that sort of a
cheat we're gonna do constantly through
this course and we'll be very clear if
we very clear any problems or anything
if we need you two to two to deviate
from that okay now what we have here in
addition to a linear angle curve is we
have an upward sloping angle curve or
positive income elasticity we call goods
with a positive income elasticity normal
Goods goods where the more money you
have the more of them you want we call
normal Goods okay because that's sort of
normal however it is also true that a
number of goods in the world actually
have gamma less than zero and we call
those inferior goods why would a good be
inferior why when your income goes up
yeah exactly any examples I want to
think of yeah
exactly grazie Omega watch this verges
relax watches I wouldn't think of them
as an inferior either of them as
inferior relevant they may be inferior
but obviously when your income goes up
you're not gonna suddenly you know
you're gonna want more both okay
where's fast food you actually would
want less of it as your income goes up
literally you will eat a McDonald's less
if you're richer
you're not gonna fewer watches if you're
richer okay so the bottom line is that
you inferior goods you're actually
getting to it's it's a bit subtle about
different goods of the same kind let's
think about classes of goods rather than
brands of goods once you get across
brains you're right don't see my class
of goods watches luxury watches in
general are clearly not inferior fast
food may be inferior literally rich or
people made probably less fast food than
poor people okay yeah that's that could
be right but yeah uh I think not because
the bottom line is rich guys are gonna
have are much more like I have two
refrigerators than one so it says it's
discreteness problem it's it's two
discrete to really use an example but I
think fast food is a great example of a
class example we use is potatoes okay
we're like in the old days like before
fast food like that was the cheap
filling shitty tasting food stuff that
guys sort of used ate all the time and
now like when they have money they say
I'm gonna move on to steak and they eat
less potatoes okay so something where
essentially you'd rather shift to
something else you have more money is
inferior
okay now moreover within that within
normal we're going to draw a distinction
between what we call luxuries and
necessities walk treats are going to be
good where gamma is greater than one and
necessities gamma is less than one so
we're gonna say essentially the question
is proportional to your budget what
happens your income goes up in other
words do you spend more and more they're
both normal goods the rich you are the
more you buy of it but a luxury good is
you spend even larger share of your of
your budget on that code as you get
richer
so that
like watches boats maybe refrigerators
etc things where the rich you get this
more of your budget you spend on it in
fear um necessities are things like food
we're clearly rich people spend more on
food than poor people but they fella
spend a smaller share of their budget on
food than poor people okay so it goes up
but doesn't go up proportion with your
income it goes up less than portion with
your income yeah yeah let's see it once
again to brands you can absolutely see
that you can think of luxury brands and
necessity brands absolutely but if you
think about stay with categories of
goods that then let's let's think you
think of you know jewelry is the clinic
on example here and sort of you know
food is the canonical example here yeah
you know there's a huge industry in
estimating these elasticity's of demand
so I'm sure there's answer that I don't
have it off the top of my head all right
so that's so that's basically so now
I've given you the underlying tools of
consumer demand theory I've told you how
to decide what quantity consumer wants
I've told you how you can use that to
derive a demand curve I've explained the
shape of the demand curve
I then talked about what happens as your
income changes and talked about the
shape of income of the income elasticity
now I'm gonna put this together to come
back to revisit something you think you
already know the answer to which is what
happens when a price changes
the effects of price change now you
might say well that's sort of silly we
already did that once this lecture we
already did when we derived the demands
curve affects the price change when we
derived the demand curve we did some
price changes right I showed you what
happened as the price cookies change but
in fact we cheated a little bit and went
we didn't cheat we gave you sort of the
bottom line but didn't get into the
elements of why that of why people react
the way they do the price changes now
we're getting to some sort of deep
theory ok now I'm going to talked about
something it's deeply theoretical in a
sense that in substance if all you care
about is what happens in the real world
they just care about when a price change
happens how does quantity change I'm
gonna need some theoretical concepts
which are gonna become very powerful
later on in the course but your poor to
understand now which is how is the
underlying decision calculus change by a
price change when the price changes and
the way we're going to do that is that
we're gonna decompose your response to a
price change into two effects the
substitution effect and the income
effect we're gonna separate your
response into two effects the separation
is going to become very important later
on the substitution effect we're going
to define we define the substitution
effect as the change in the quantity of
a good when the price changes hold the
utility constant so it's Delta Q Delta
DQ DP okay for shorthand but holding
utility constant at some fixed level you
bar the change in quantities price
changes so it's the elasticity of demand
but at a constant level of utility the
income effect is the change in quantity
of a good as income changes change in
quantity DUI which is the income
elasticity we talked about okay the
change in quantity um as the income
changes okay and this is actually
multiple it's multiplied by the initial
level of income either
we'll learn about this in section but
that's technically how the income effect
is defined and you'll come into section
about why that is but we're gonna
decompose this so let me that's sort of
confusing so let me start by graphically
to understand it so let's go to figure
four or five one of the more complicated
figures okay
we start at budget constraint one same
parameters as always all the math here
all this graphical stuff follows from
the math using that utility function and
these prices in income same as before so
we start as before at Point a your
tangency is the best package you can
have given that utility function is six
cookies and three slices of pizza
okay now let's change now let's imagine
a price of cookies rises to nine dollars
the price of cookies in our example
price of cookies goes from $6 to $9 okay
that's example gonna analyze now we know
from before that we'll only move you
from six cookies to four cookies while
holding pizzas constant at three so we
know you'll end up you'll end up at
Point C we did that before but actually
two things are happening to get you
there
the first thing that's happening is the
substitution effect which is the change
in prices with utility constant and how
do we measure that we want to ask given
that the price changed but the utilities
constant how what's the new quantity to
choose what is utility constant need in
this graph what does it mean known
utility constant she had some other
folks involved here what does it mean
yeah same indifference curve so Wanda
has asked given the new prices but the
old indifference curve what quantity
would you choose well the way we do that
is we find the tangency between the new
slope of the budget constraint and the
old and difference curve and we do that
by drawing sort of an imaginary budget
constraint B C prime B C prime is a sort
of imaginary budget constraint it's not
a real budget constraint but it has the
slope of the new budget constraint but
it's tangent to the old indifference
curve that's the key thing B C Prime the
imaginary budget constraint the dashed
line
has the slope of the new budget strength
same as the new price ratio so the slope
is the new price ratio the slope is the
slope is now is that the new price ratio
but it's tangent to the old indifference
curve so BC prime is basically going to
detention sealed inverse curve at point
B so we're saying is the substitution
effect moves you from point A to point B
that is holding utility constant but at
these new prices you would choose to
have fewer cookies and less pizza okay
we call this notion compensated demand
compensated demand that is I'm
compensating you I'm holding utility
constant I'm saying price of change
sucks for you you're worse off your
opportunity sets restricted but I'm
going to compensate you by holding a
utility constant
let's go let's compensate a demand
you're compensated demand would mean
that when the price goes up you would
choose to reduce your consumption of
cookies from six to four point eight
nine okay now here's the key thing about
substitution effects we can sign them
definitively they are always negative
the substitution effect is always
negative okay so check there's always
negative the income effect could go
other way we'll show that so G of X is
always negative okay we can see this in
two ways graphically think about it this
way you have to be tangent to the same
indifference curve with a higher sloped
line so you have to move to the left
right if we change to the same
indifference curve of the line with a
higher slope it's gotta be to the left
so that's the graphical intuition
mathematically it's worth writing out
the steps because it helps us okay
that's why we teaches you up sir - of
our consumer theory okay step one you're
at this new tangency okay step two we
know that at any such tangency that's
optimized the margin utility of cookies
over the Marg utilities Pizza equals the
price of cookies over the price of Pizza
we know that's sure at any tangency okay
cuz that's the optimal choice step 3
we know PC over P P is up okay that's I
just said that it's assumptions the
price cookies up therefore that leads to
step four which is the MU C over mu P
must be up because it's still equal well
how do you raise the ratio the Mars
utility cookies to Marge utility pizzas
how do you accomplish that by having
fewer cookies and more Pizza the way you
get so that means that implies that
cookies are up I'm sorry cookies are
down in pizzas are up and or pizzas are
up okay how do you get that ratio to be
higher well remember this is why I do
this math here remember the key
intuition more cookies means lower large
utility of cookies the more cookies you
have the less you care about the next
cookie so I want the Marge utility of
cookies to be lower if on tomorrow
chilly cookies I'm sorry to be higher
I've got to have fewer cookies or I've
got to have more pizza or both okay so
the substitution effect is always
negative if I'm gonna hold you till 'ti
constant and change prices and raise a
price you'll always want less that good
from the substitution effect okay
question about the graphics of the math
okay now let's come to the income effect
the income effect says being effect says
hold the income effect is saying holding
prices constant so I should have put
this here the income effect is this in a
constant price should add that think of
effect is the change in quantity
demanded as income changes holding
prices constant so now we're saying the
income effect is saying look the price
changed so therefore I shifted my
consumption towards away from cookies
but the other thing that happened is I
got poorer they might even get poor your
parents didn't tell you less money but
remember your opera
reset restricted you effectively are
poor because this price went up how do
we represent that well we can exactly
represent that by the shift from BC
prime to BC to because b c prime and bc
to have the same slope that shift is
just the income effect so that's holding
the prices constant the price ratio for
bc prime + bc - is the same okay but
you're now effectively poor because you
at the same income you can afford fewer
cookies she effectively poor so now your
incomes effectively falling and at that
new budget constraint with that new
lower effective income and higher price
ratio you choose Point C so we got from
A to C just like I told you before but
we actually get there are two steps one
step is sort of the relative change in
prices cause say oh I want to get away
from cookies the other say I'm poorer
salt less of everything including
cookies okay so when it's a price effect
ones income effect and it matters these
two effects matter now in this case they
don't matter because they work together
in this case you might say well look why
do I care you know why do i the bottom
line is number cookies fell by to
substitute in fact work together why do
I care well you might care because if
the income effect is is because if the
good is inferior then the income a
substitution effect work against each
other if the good is inferior then the
income soutien effects work against each
other rather than with each other to see
this let's go to figure four six now
we're going to totally change our
example okay now I want to choose them
between steak and potatoes totally for
an example steak and potatoes you start
a budget BC one potatoes are a dollar
and steak is five dollars so our new
example in our new example I'll put this
up here
in our new example we've got the price
of steak is $5 the price of potatoes is
$1 okay and your income is $25 that's
our new example okay in that case you
will choose and this is a differential
function it's a totally new example I'm
not gonna you know I'm not expected I
say in the underlying math here I'm just
showing you an example of something that
might be true okay so you choose point a
you choose seven-and-a-half potatoes and
three and a half steaks okay given those
given those prices now we're gonna say
what happens if the price of potatoes
goes from $1 to $3 the price of potatoes
goes up well two things happen first of
all the change in compensated demand
moves you from point A to point B how do
we know that because we draw a new
imaginary budget constraint that has the
new price ratio but it's tangent to the
old and difference curve it's your point
A to point B so the substitution effect
lowers our demand for potatoes from
seven and a half to four but the income
effect raises your demand for potatoes
now the income effect means you actually
move back from four to five uh net you
solve and fewer potatoes but the
substitution effects went opposite ways
why why do the income effect cause you
to want to have more potatoes
substituteph economic add less yeah
clothes prices went up so are you you're
effectively what poorer right and when
you're poor how does that affect your
consumption of fear your goods you want
more of them right so price painters
went up so effectively you're poor now
when you're poor in our previous example
with cookies you want a fewer cookies
they're normal good but potatoes are
inferior good
so as you're poor you want more of them
singham effect goes the opposite way the
substitution effect that's where this
starts to get interesting
thinking effect always goes the same way
the substitution effect this is sort of
just a purely useless theoretical
exercise it gets interesting we think of
effect goes the opposite way the
substitution effect yeah oh I'm getting
there I'm getting there okay so yeah you
just usually well different ility
functions will give you different you
have to have a different utility
function to get the good to be inferior
so you till it was think of potatoes
could be it's not gonna be square root
of you won't get inferior already with
square root of P times s so it's a
different utility function I mention
that I think it's a difference to the
function yeah so basically your
intuition I give you Jewish rather
inferior but mathematically would occur
because we'd have utility function these
are the function with generate and fear
it could be a different looking utility
function but well well we'll do it in
section okay
so the bottom line is yeah
safely the crisis today examle 500 at
the state is equivalent I'm not right
now to health function I'm right I
didn't write it down it's a utility
function so it's about filling up it's
about taste steak maybe leave me
hungrier but it's way better so it's not
about what fills me up literally all I'm
saying is give my utility function I
don't have the utility function written
down but given my chili function I was
choosing a balance of most of potatoes
in some steak now the price piñas goes
up III end up wanting fewer potatoes but
not as few as you might think for the
substitution effect because potatoes are
inferior ya know what I'm saying the
income effect is holding the price
constant what happens to demand so
holding the price constant what I mean
by that is moving from BC prime to be c2
is the income effect holding your price
constant so the price change is
reflecting the substitution effect
that's reflected in moving for be c1 to
be C prime the income effect is holding
the price constant that is given that
same slope of that imaginary new budget
constraint you're now poor so that's why
so it's it's once against a hard thing
to wrap your mind around theoretical but
the notion is when a price changes two
things happen it changes the relative
desirability of two goods and it changes
your income your effective income your
opportunity set two things are happening
okay yeah they both have at the same
time let's be clear this isn't
sequential this happening in real time
it's not like you said the price went up
I'm going to compute my you know it's
happening in real time it's just we're
decomposing into two effects and the
reason is the reason we're doing that is
because once goods are inferior this
decomposition becomes interesting okay
so let's think about I like to think
about this as sort of a simple a simple
table to help sort of remind you how to
think about this let's give a simple
table here we have the price change okay
so the price can go up and go up or the
price can go down up and down here we
have the substitution effect
here we have the income effect and here
we have the total okay well in the case
of a normal good so in the case of a
normal good if a good is normal then we
know the substitution effect when the
price goes up leads you don't want less
of a good the income effect also leads
you want less of a good so you
definitely want less of a good these are
all equals
there's always corner cases okay
likewise so the price falls the
substitution effect what you want more
than good when the price falls you're
effectively richer so the income effect
makes you want more of the good so you
clearly want more than good okay that's
the easy case the more interesting case
is what if it's an inferior good now if
the price goes up the substitution
effect is to sing some sense factor is
always negative higher price means you
substitute away from the good but the
income effect is now positive so the net
is unclear likewise if the price goes
down price goes down the substitution
effect is always positive you always
want more of the good if the price goes
down but the income effect is now you
want less of the good why because you're
richer if the price of a good Falls
you're richer richer means want less of
that inferior good so the net effect is
unclear so the interesting case becomes
inferior goods okay questions about the
table so this raises the question are
there goods what does this imply if this
was actually if this was if the income
effect dominate the substitution effect
you could get what yeah
yes you can get an upward sloping demand
curve you could actually theoretically
get an upward sloping demand curve and
we call this a Giffen good a Giffen good
is a good where you can upward sloping
demand curve where actually the inferior
income effect is so large it dominates
the substitution effect and you're
actually an upward sloping demand curve
that a higher price leads people want
more of the good now in fact this is
named after giving some guy Giffen i
guess and probably was a guy because
it's old okay um but in fact it's
convenient because it's close to the
word Griffin and Griffin's are imaginary
and so are Givens okay it's actually
hard to find examples in reality of
giving goods okay it's actually pretty
hard to find examples in reality okay
but there was um one interesting
experiment that was run which is sort of
the first convincing evidence that in
some situations Giffen goods could exist
so ran the following experiment
they run a study in China where um very
very poor households they based all
house most hostels in China are poor but
they surviving the super poor versus
moderately poor households okay
and they basically gave them coupons
which lowered the price of rice which
was their staple good okay they
basically they eat rice and that's sort
of their basic goodnight and they
basically lowered the price of rice what
they found is that for families that
weren't super poor they found a typical
downward sloping demand curve given the
coupon off rice meant they bought more
rice
but for the very very poor families they
actually did find an upward sloping
demand curve giving them a discount the
price of rice actually caused and have
less rice because they were they were it
was because literally it's all they ever
ate was rice so by definition they could
have had more because they didn't eat
anything else now that you're
essentially saying look do you see tall
rice you spend your whole budget of rice
now I'm basically giving you extra money
because all that rice you see you can
now have cheaper are you gonna spend
that to buy more rice no you gonna buy
something else and that's a Giffen good
so you can think if you think about sort
of a corner solution when people buying
all of a
that's inferior that by definition if
you give them more money they're gonna
move on to another good or there's at
least a possibility and that's a given
good example but we have to search
pretty darn hard typically in the man
context we think that demand curves are
downward sloping however when we get to
other contexts we're gonna find it's
more normal to find that these income
and substitution effects fight against
each other and lead to strange shape
curves and we'll come back to that later
in the course okay um okay I'll see you
all Wednesday